How do you spend your free time?
Most weekends, my husband and I work around the house or do shopping,...
...but we both enjoy tennis.
Sometimes, we play at the tennis courts by our house.
Oh, you're a tennis fan!
What do you do on weekends?
I usually join the club activity.
I go out shopping with my friends.
I sometimes help my mother with the housecleaning.
My name is Luna Ruiz.
I am a senior in high school, and I live in New York City.
I was always very adventurous and curious,...
...and that's why I got into computer science...
...'cause I was always curious about how things work.
Well, other than computer science, I'm into sports.
I'm a serious athlete.
I play volleyball, softball, and basketball.
I'm really competitive, as you can see.